the first film in phase three comes out
next May and it's called Captain America
Civil War this film this film the third
in the Captain America series which I
believe is is going to be one of the
most unique trilogies of all time you
met him for the first time in Captain
America the Winter Soldier Sam Wilson
the Falcon himself Anthony Mackie
everybody thank y'all for being here
Doctor Strange looks crazy right I mean
that's amazing that's amazing but we're
here at d23 thank you guys for having me
we flew all the way from Germany last
night so I'm a little tired but I made
it I made it but y'all know I'm not the
only person to come and introduce
Captain America Civil War right I can't
come introduce the Civil War without
Captain America
hello the standard
hi everybody I'll keep it over here all
day we're here oh man I'm so happy to be
here I I'm a big I'm a big big big
Disney fan you know my whole family we
grew up loving Disney that was the place
we all wanted to go as kids and to this
day that's kind of its that that's
that's my idea of of heaven and it's
just it's it's it's an amazing
experience to be to be somehow in any
capacity involved with them to be to be
a part of that family if I'm having a
bad day I go online and just watch like
I watch other people's home movies I'm
not you know just watching other
people's experience at Disney it's it's
just it's a really fantastic and then we
go in our trailer and sing the frozen
theme some things were very honored to
be here and if you think we would come
this far without actually having some
footage did you bring the show use yeah
nice you'd be crazy we eat this together
on our computers he really rough last
minute it was we learned iMovie on the
plane
we were we were on set and I was like
Chris we need to take our phones record
this and then bring it to d23 with but I
think we did a good job it looks pretty
good
you